you think about the whole visit from
Nick Fuentes and Kanye West going to
marlago what are your thoughts on that
um honestly I didn't this is the first
time I heard of this so I don't know if
I have anything worthwhile even talking
about okay Adam what do you think about
it
look
um
this was not a good look for Donald
Trump okay so
um Trump's been known that if someone
likes me I like them right like that's
sort of his thing if he says nice things
about me I like them now right but this
was the exact opposite of a positive
direction for Trump I mean the the
bottom line is you have people
that were so staunchly in his Camp you
see what Ann Coulter just said no Ann
Coulter was if you recall of course the
first person
she was the first person they laughed at
it they laughed her off stage everyone
oh you dumb [ __ ] you don't know nothing
it turns out she was right that's right
she is now basically saying I am so done
with this guy read the news Ann
coulter's saying this then you've got
you know the whole Fox Murdoch situation
Murdoch's done with him right there's
this Groundswell of people just saying
like look man you've done some good
stuff you've done some bad stuff
time to exit stage left and when I say
that I don't mean like the 30 of America
that is his staunch base sure I mean
everyone else and that's the problem in
this country right now is that 30 of the
car look right here right wing Pond and
colder dismisses Ronald Trump says he's
so dumb and you've got the mcconnels of
the world and you've got the bill bars
of the world and the VP Mike Pence of
the world all basically saying look Don
thank you for everything we're kind of
over you and then who's everybody you
know the latest uh flavor of the day is
everybody's on DeSantis right now and
for this isn't even my opinion who cares
what Adam has to say I don't think he's
the flavor of the day I think he's
growing because of his performance as a
governor through that let's be fair with
that correct but the the reason why he's
in the National media is because he's
the counterpart or the the better
alternative to Trump that's sort of how
the media is portraying him but forget
about what Adam thinks forget about
Republicans think what you need to focus
on is what Independents think we all we
all just saw what happened in the
midterms you know
Republicans are supposed to run away
with this thing were they not like it
was supposed to be a bloodbath what they
call it a red wave it was like a red
teardrop because
Independence broke overwhelmingly for
the Democrats and if you want to win in
this country we say this is still
shocking to me well but but here's my
point if your vote was counted don't be
shocked if it happens again right and if
if you want to like for me but how bad
does it have to get I mean under under
Biden how bad does the country have to
get for somebody to go I don't know I'm
not really in like the complaining
business I'm in like the just looking at
the facts business
right now they just did polling like do
you want Trump to run again 80 of
Republicans said yes 90 of Democrats
said no right obviously clear but 60 of
Independents said no that's the number
you need to look at so if he loses don't
be like well what don't you get it we're
in energy independent there's this
clamoring for basically Americans saying
thank you so much
please exit stage left so if he loses
again in 2024 because he'll likely get
the nomination unless there's something
goes terribly wrong you already have the
answer there but back to the Nick
Fuentes thing I don't know Nick Fuentes
you know I don't know much of his
content but we talked about a narrative
we talked about the narrative even when
we talked about Patrick Mahomes the
other day like his narrative is he's
going to win the big game and that's
exactly what happened when he played
against the Chargers The Narrative of
this guy Nick Fuentes is that he's a
white nationalist and a holocaust denier
so that's the type of person that you're
having at Mar-A-Lago and there's no
vetting process so just Kanye shows up
like hey Kanye here not sure if you've
heard what I'm doing in the news these
days but pretty much hate the Jews
trying to go Defcon 3 on the Jews by the
way I'm gonna bring a holocaust denier
with me we're gonna hang out with you
for a little while Trump yeah okay and
now Trump's walking this back and last
point I said you my friend that I've
referenced all the time he's the biggest
Trump Maga guy in my life Joe you know
I'm talking about him he texted me the
other day he goes I'm officially done
with Donald Trump I said what do you
talk like when I say Kevin if you think
you're a hardcore Trump supporter he's
going to make you look like a woke
liberal that's how hardcore he is he
said yeah I can no longer support this
guy who's basically hanging around with
Holocaust deniers yeah uh so that this
is when you're losing guys like that
that's not a good sign
yeah let me read you what Trump said
here so I help a seriously troubled man
who just happened to be black yay Kanye
West who has been decimated in his
business and virtually everything else
and has always been good to me by
allowing his requests for meeting at
Mar-A-Lago alone so that I can give him
very much needed advice he shows up with
three people two of which I don't know
the other political person who I haven't
seen in years I told them don't run for
office a total waste of time can't win
fake news went viral went crazy so
that's the response now you know
um
but he's so he's calling Kanye troubled
great and and by the way Kanye was on
Temple yesterday right was it yesterday
or day before yeah he walked off he
walked up because I'm talking [ __ ] about
Jews again yeah he walked off within the
first 10 minutes and who was on it Milo
was on it and Nick was on it so that's
the crew the three of them that are
together going around talking about what
they're talking about I don't know look
here's here's a couple things that is
not a good idea
in a Marketplace whether you like it or
not you're going to be judged by who's
around you okay if that's how it is in
business that's how it is in sports
that's how it is in everything you do if
you come up and say your campaign is you
Milo and Nick Fuentes I had a meeting
with Milo once six years ago five years
ago I don't know what timeline it was I
was I don't know I was in Orlando or
somewhere like that and we met up uh and
we had a conversation together about his
father I want to say I think we even
have a video we never went live with it
uh about his upbringing house
relationship was what is that that's
where my curiosity was with Milo I don't
know who Nick is but for a trump you
gotta know who's coming to your place
and you got to filter those people out
and for Kanye you know you wanted to run
at a time like this and you're going
around uh walking off of sets anytime
somebody walks off a set
I I don't know if that's showing any
kind of strength with where you're at it
wasn't a good look did you actually see
the podcast on what happened what led to
him getting off like did you watch the
whole thing yeah I watched I watched the
clip of walking I'll see him walking up
no I didn't get a chance to see it I
don't know uh oh
but so we're talking about a couple
different things here but all the stars
are aligning with Kanye this guy Nick
Fuentes coming to Trump so it just seems
to me like if we can go to Kanye for a
second
like
what is he trying to prove here
like okay you have a beef with certain
people in the music space or in the
business world who happen to be Jewish
believe me I'm Jewish it's not like I'm
getting these phone calls to to discuss
uh Kanye's label it's not all Jews are
painted in this broad brush these are
these people you're doing business with
and the reason you're doing business
with them is because they probably
invented the company like they forgot
that Jews you might know this better
than me Kevin invented Hollywood they
invented it's not like they just were
plucked out all right Jews you run it
the Warner Brothers they started the
business shout out to Brian Callan for
informing me of all this stuff but like
you're like what's your beef what's your
point you you want to expose the people
that started the company that happened
to be the people that that you have a
beef with but so Kanye
you know if there's anything I can say
about Kanye musical genius no doubt but
we talked about his blind spots
narcissist not able to just basically
heed advice who's in your ear stuff that
we talk about all the time here but
you're basically saying yeah I've got
myself in all this hot water whether you
agree with it or not he's in hot water
and you're saying let me go bring this
white Christian nationalist
white supremacists what he's labeled as
Nick Fuentes around with me everywhere
now let me take them to Mar-A-Lago and
and destroy my relationship with Trump
let me bring him on podcasts and
basically and if you're this guy Nick
Fuentes and Connie wants to take you all
around what are you gonna say of course
he loves the world sign me up bro my
name's all over them but I tell you I
tell you I tell you one thing as well
and there are certain labels that that
hurts it's courier-ending labels just so
you know uh uh
anti-semite you know racist a white
supremacist a white nationalist a pedo a
at any of this yes right these labels
are uh being dropped a Nazi they
bringing dropped left and right and you
just a bigot these are very powerful
labels that people put on you it's an
incredible strategy to do with anybody
because immediately 99 of people who
don't know who that guy is they're gonna
be like oh that's that's what he is done
I'm moving on
misogynist don't I'm not talking to
YouTube this I'm gonna that doesn't have
to be proof at all yeah so so to me in
that part I've never watched a single
piece of content of Nick I have no idea
how many times have you guys brought him
up as potentially somebody to have on
the podcast and then right it's coming
his name's come up a few times I'm like
guys I I haven't seen anything to see so
I can't make an educated decision on
where he's at all I know is as a person
that tries to
do his best as an emotional being to
process with reason uh uh I have to sit
there and reason uh on who he is I don't
know him yet so I can't jump to
conclusion and say he is that or he's
not that okay
uh people change but Connie is strategy
on how he's communicating there is a
risk when you take a position and you
put it out there Trump took a risk when
he said the borders all these people are
coming across their rapists they're this
they're that Max that that that
statement came with a lot of risk and it
was on him the next six to 12 months to
sell everybody on why that's a risk and
an American said okay yeah let me tell
you why we need to build a wall and
first reaction everybody's like what
yeah with China's got a wall this world
why can't we have a wall you live in a
house Nancy Pelosi's got a gated
community with walls around her house so
let me get this straight it's okay for
people to build a wild house around a
wall against their house but it's not
okay to build a wall against your
country what's wrong with that such and
such Doesn't and you're like oh wow okay
voter ID Mexico does voter ID why can't
we do voter ID no no you're like oh so
these are things that you have to sell
and Kanye hasn't done a good job selling
that's all there is to it if he was a
better salesperson of the controversial
argument he made then the audience would
say oh okay that's you know what
fine that's a that's a good point he's
not been able to sell this point your
job as a campaigner is to sell a point
for others to say that makes sense that
hasn't happened to enough people yet
order your future looks bright hat click
over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody